what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be telling you guys
a story about something that just
happened so
i was talking to a friend and she has a
really like pessimistic view of men
because her last
boyfriend cheated on her but it's really
interesting because
she actually cheated on her first
boyfriend and led her like first
boyfriend on like
for like years or months years whatever
it was
second boyfriend she's super in love
with super indie he
he cheated on her like all the time and
she chose to stay with him though after
like it happened the first time so it
wasn't like a one-time thing like
literally kept happening
and due to that like she genuinely
thinks better trash she thinks like then
she
um you're gonna get cheated on whatever
and
i told her i'm like
a girl it's your own fault if you pick
like if you pick guys that constantly
cheat on you and you don't leave when
they cheat on you
you can't complain about getting cheated
on
if you're gonna date guys that cheat on
you and not leave when they do
i don't understand what where the the
disconnect is
and the crazy thing is like i genuinely
believe
like that karma is real and you reap
what you sow so
she's gonna talk about how men are
trashed even though she did the same
thing
in her first relationship like
and then the crazy thing is this girl
has her butt all over her inspect
her all over her instagram like very
scandalous like clothes all the time
that's how she portrays herself and then
you get confused when you date guys that
only want you for that one thing
like sorry
um and i'm never i'm never gonna say
like
that it's a a hundred percent the girl's
fault if you get cheated on like
that sucks i'm i'm sorry that's like a
terrible position to be put in
but if you don't leave and he keeps
doing it that's your own fault
and point number two
if you constantly are posting your body
and you show nothing on social media
other than your body you're going to
attract a god a lot of guys that
only watch you for that so if that's
what you want to do like it's not my
life
i do not care at all but
you can't be mad
when you attract guys that are in it for
the wrong thing so
i don't know that's just my two cents
but let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or you disagree
because i was just thinking about this
the other day and i'm like
this girl puts her naked body all over
her instagram and wonders why guys only
want her for it like
sorry i don't know let me know don't
forget to subscribe